in the play and it's kind of cool the
way the author's I think it's done a
brilliant job in in in in weaving an
actual history because let's face the
language style is much different in the
1700 this today but they were able to
weave that into something that was very
entertaining and and enjoyable and when
I was teaching school it was great
although I do have to admit at one time
I had a kid that was debating me on
whether this was realistic or not and I
said yeah it was pretty close to history
and he finally looked at me and said you
mean they sang back then so I had to it
no no this is a musical they didn't
really sing and then we went on with it
and at one time we were watching the
movie and he turned around and he said
what were they talking about
and I finally said the Revolutionary War
he waited a few minutes and then said
did we win it I realized I had a lot of
work to do with this kid book TV wants
to know what you're reading this summer
tweet us your answer at book TV or you
can post it on our Facebook page
facebook.com slash book TV
welcome to Provo Utah on book TV located
45 miles south of Salt Lake City Provo
is the third largest city in the state
with a population of over 112,000 people
originally named fort Utah it was
settled by Mormon families in 18-49 and
today is home to Brigham Young
University with the help of our comcast
cable partners for the next hour we'll
learn about Provos history and literary
culture from local authors we begin with
J Spencer flume Anan anti Mormonism in
the US and his book a peculiar people
for me and my my own research it's
unmistakable that Mormonism has drawn
more than its fair share and this
weekend were in Provo Utah with the help
of our local cable partner Comcast next
we visit moons rare books and see
Brigham Young's copy of the Book of
Mormon as well as an original copy of
Thomas Paine's Common Sense
I've been collecting rare blue
past 30 years I decided to relocate to
Provo after selling my book shop in
Dallas which also sold new books and the
past 10 to 15 years book stores that
have sold new books have really suffered
with the advent of e-books and
everything going digital but what I
found is the interest in rare books has
increased in my shop right now there are
about a thousand books but in my
inventory there are about 5,000 books I
wrote eight books through here and I
specialize in four different areas I
specialize in rare Bibles older Bibles
Bibles from the past 500 years being in
Utah specialize in early mormon books
classics and literature and early
american history one of the items i
enjoy collecting our Bibles or religious
texts that belong to well-known
historical figures and being from utah
one of the more popular items that i
like to show people is Brigham Young's
copy of the Book of Mormon it's housed
in a nice protective clamshell but this
is according to family tradition this is
the copy of the Book of Mormon that was
on Brigham Young's nightstand when he
died in 1877 and if you open it up to
the title page you can see Brigham
Young's signature another one in my I
enjoy early American history and this is
really one of the most important books
printed in America pre 1800 and it's an
original copy of Thomas Paine's Common
Sense which was printed in Philadelphia
the printer was Robert Bell was on Third
Street in Philadelphia and if you go
there today you'll see a brass plaque
saying here is where common sense was
printed January 9th 1776 now it was a
little like a pamphlet it's sewn
together and it's quite rare and it was
printed three times in January of 1776
and it has an interesting story because
Thomas Paine went to Robert Bell wanted
to have this printed and he wanted the
proceeds to buy salt by the soldiers
mittens well after it went through three
printings they had a falling out and so
Thomas Paine allowed anybody to print it
he lowered the price and said anybody
can print it and that's one reason that
book is so well known and printed and so
this day has the designation of having
the highest saturation of any book ever
printed in America my favorite find in
the past year is a Bible that belonged
to the man who wrote Lord of the Rings
so I have JRR Tolkien's copy of the
Bible and I had a nice protective case
made for it but he had a very simple
Bible it was printed in 1947 this is in
the middle of writing Lord of the Rings
he was writing Lord of the Rings from
1937 to 1954 and you can see his
beautiful well known recognizable
signature in the front but what most
interests me about this book is the fact
that he annotated this book and made
comments in the margin and here in the
last page of John you can see he's
making comments and Greek he's comparing
it to seven different versions of the
Bible he's making saying this is a
better translation of this Greek of the
original Greek and so JRR Tolkien's
Bible it's the one he had while he was
writing Lord of the Rings just the
thousand books in here are worth over 10
million and there are actually there's
even a few books that are worth over a
million apiece although I have books as
low as $100 but that's kind of the
starting level for the books that I have
what I enjoy so much about the rare
books
it's the trek it's the hunt it's so that
it's a treasure hunt it's finding them
and then also realizing that in these
older books they're different
they have a different feel a different
look and often a different story often
depending on who owned the books that's
an added story within a story
[Music]
this is a pert the perfect place to keep
these books because it's fireproof its
humidity controlled and there's no UV
light this little book has a big story
but if you're looking at it you'll see
that it's in Latin and this is something
that could be overlooked unless you
understand what this symbol is this
little book has a great story but you
have to know history you have to
understand the history of this time
period to understand who owned this book
so it's you almost have to do detective
work now to determine who owned this
book you look at this and when you see
this you see a crown so that makes you
think royalty you go okay well now you
see the fleur-de-lis
so you think okay that's French royalty
but why do you see the two sides well
this is because this person was married
so this would be a Queen's copy the King
at the time was louis xvi this is the
seal of Marie Antoinette and this if
it's in Latin you may not recognize the
book and he may overlook that but if you
know what Marie Antoinette's seal looked
like you would be able to identify this
and there are very few of her books that
have survived in private hands because
when she was executed her libraries were
absorbed into the French National
Library but this would have been a
little book that she carried with her
and she would have had more than one
this is something that each year showed
they were given a new copy so she would
have had a few and that's why she could
have given this copy away and that's why
it is currently not in the French
National Library and finally another fun
book I have as a Shakespeare book it's
quite rare Shakespeare died in 1616 and
in 1623 his complete works were first
printed and then again in 1632 and 1664
in 1685 only about 250 of each of these
copies have survived
so there's maybe a thousand copies in
the world and of those thousand the vast
majority over 90% are institutionally
owned but I have a fourth folio 1685 and
even before you open the book you know
that book has a story to tell it's just
a stunning binding with working class
but it's the complete works of
Shakespeare done in 616 85 and I have it
open to Romeo and Juliet I will continue
to collect books for the rest of my life
I have had people ask me when are you
going to retire what are you going to do
I'm already doing I can't think of
anything I would rather do than travel
around tracking down rare books I enjoy
these books I people ask do you read
them absolutely I will go through you
never know if one of the earlier owners
has made an inscription that could
substantially increase the value of the
book or add added interest to this story
behind the book and so I will always do
this I never get tired of it I love
sharing stories with old and young and I
look forward to every day as book shops
have been closing in record numbers
national chains are closing down 15
years ago I knew owners of about 300
book stores 250 of those closed just in
the past 15 years so it's it's important
for these stores to continue to survive
they add character to the local
community it's a place a meeting place
for people and it keeps history alive by
these book shops continuing to be an
existence
during book TV's recent visit to Provo
Utah we spoke with Earl Frey about his
vision for the country and his book
revitalizing governance restoring
prosperity and reconstructing foreign
affairs
generally about 2/3 say the country is
moving in the wrong direction
almost half of parents say that they
think that their their children will not
do as well as the parents have done in
adulthood so there's some discouragement
out there about the future of the United
States in part because a fair number of
households have not done too well
financially not much in the way of
raises not much in the way of increased
fringe benefits but at the same time
their health care costs are going up
costs of education particularly at the
college level going up and so the
feeling is that there's a lot more money
going out but not as much coming in and
so there one green
are we being a service well by our
political leaders in Washington DC what
do we need to change in order that my
own individual circumstances will
improve significantly coming out of
World War two and then moving
particularly through the early 70s we
did very well and keep in mind it was
amazing at the under world war two we
had had over 14 million people in
uniform and we had to bring most of them
home and what were they going to do but
we were able to basically get young men
and women into colleges and universities
get them enough jobs as we move from a
wartime economy to a civilian economy
and we did very well and you could come
out of school with a high school
education and generally get a good job
particularly in the manufacturing sector
as we moved to 1945 where the United
States alone accounted for almost half
of everything that was being produced in
the world and when you combine that with
the fact that we had the strongest
military we had a monopoly on atomic
weapons I argue in the book that the
United States may well have been the
most powerful superpower ever in terms
of its global reach and of course then
it made sense as time would go on that
the devastation of Europe parts of Asia
you know would
would go away those people would get
back on their feet and our share of
global gross domestic product and other
things would go down and they have but
we're still a very significant economy
in the world
although when measured and what the
economists call purchasing power parity
taking out the you know factoring out
the differentials and currencies our
share of global GDP gross domestic
product today is probably the lowest
it's been in about a century or so and
most Americans think that our influence
globally has been going down rather
significantly and that we have to adjust
the changing circumstances we're still a
superpower but not as dominant as we
once were and with the world changing
becoming more complex that we have to
adjust to that and do the best that we
can both internationally and at home to
preserve the security of our people and
also the prosperity how did this change
happen basically in part other nations
have grown more rapidly than we have
during the past several years we also
went into a period of slower economic
growth and of course we look at the the
economic miracle if we can call it in
China where literally since the end of
the 1970s hundreds of millions of
Chinese have been brought out of poverty
and of course the Chinese economy
growing much more rapidly than our own
through much of this period and that has
also happened in many of what we call
the emerging markets other developing
countries as well so you know we are our
share of things have gone down whether
it's a share of world exports a world
GDP world foreign direct investment and
stuff like that but pretty probably
we're reaching a balance somewhere and
there's no reason why this can't be a
win-win situation in terms of they can
do well in the countries around us but
we can do well too and we'll just expand
that economic pie and and hopefully take
into account environmental conditions as
well and not degrade our environment and
that will have a good standard of living
good quality of life and so will more
and more people around the world and so
that's what we hope for as time goes on
but there's no doubt that the US
influence is not as great as it once was
that we're going to have to cooperate
more with other nations not be as
unilateral at times ism as we have in
the past and and we're getting used to
that and we're not quite sure what what
the best way to do it is and so the
American people again and looking at the
u.s. role in the in the world saying
well we're not as influential as we once
were you know or a plurality of
Americans sort of think that this 21st
century maybe the Asian Asian century
instead of the American Century whereas
it was very clear that the 20th century
was the American Century so we're going
to have to adjust Americans are somewhat
upset by this relative lack of our or
drop in our influence and our position
in the world and but beyond that I think
it's what I call the triple combination
in the book expanding globalization
unprecedented technology change and also
the creative destruction and what I mean
by creative destruction it comes from a
famous Austrian American economist is
basically we simultaneously create and
we destroy businesses and jobs and let
me give you an illustration of that in
the year 2014 we had a pretty good year
we created three million net new jobs in
the United States but what really
happened was we created 29 point 1
million new jobs but we lost 26 point 1
million so yeah 3 million net new jobs
that's very good but what if you're
among the 26 point 1 million where the
job and what if you're a 55 year old
steel worker and all of a sudden you're
out of a job where are you going to
replicate that wage and those fringe
benefits that you have received for so
many years and so with this triple
combination of change and its current
it's occurring so rapidly Americans are
worried they're worried about their own
futures they're worried about their kids
futures when we'd be able to keep up as
a nation
you know what we
we be qualified for our jobs how about
the competition with other countries how
well we do so we're living in an age
almost like no other age in our history
in terms of the rapidity of change and
naturally people are thinking well I'm
not sure I like this and but we're going
to have to adapt to it which means
almost lifelong learning lifelong
lifelong re training for our jobs
because we're probably doubling our
database you know every year or two now
unlike any other time in human history
and so will we be able to keep pace and
so with that I think the average
American says oh yeah you know I we
really have to be concerned about this
and and one of the great tragedies I
think that we we now face in the United
States we have about twenty percent of
our young people dropping out of school
before graduating from high school and
they're the ones that are really going
to struggle this time goes on they're
going to have jobs which may not pay
nearly as much as the average job pays
and and doing a labor that a lot of
other people will not have to do and
that obviously shows that we have to put
much greater emphasis on our K through
12 education we sort of do you know and
we're middling in terms of how we
compare with other advanced industrial
societies in terms of results in science
and mathematics and reading
comprehension and so we really do need
to put more of an emphasis on what we're
doing in the schools we're losing 20% of
our new school teachers within three
years we're losing 50% within five years
in major urban areas in contrast for
example in Finland where I had the
opportunity to to teach for a year all
the students who want to become teachers
have to have a graduate degree in a
certain discipline and to get into the
University of Helsinki in terms of being
a teacher being prepared to teach in K
through 12 it's more difficult to get
into the University of Helsinki if you
want to be a teacher than to go to law
school or to medical school you know
they're that they put that much emphasis
on the importance of teaching young
people and we probably have to do that
as well you know pay our teachers better
giving better compensation better
working conditions but understand we are
raising the new generation of leadership
that will face changes like we never
faced during our lifetimes and the
rapidity have changed like we never
faced and so we have to do more in this
area because even though we're rich in
natural resources in the 21st century
the most important natural resource is a
human resource and it's brain power and
so we have to make sure that our young
people are given the training they need
so that they can compete very
effectively in a world that is
undergoing significant change during
book TV's recent visit to Provo Utah we
toured the Crandall historical printing
Museum and discussed the advances made
in the printing process
we're here at the Crandall historical
printing Museum in Provo Utah this
museum has been here for around eighteen
to twenty years here at the museum we
tell the history of printing from the
beginning and we do it by telling the
history of the printing of the
scriptures which is appropriate since
the first book printed is a movable
metal type wants the Bible so that's
where we start
Louis Crandall is that founder in the
owner of this museum he is an old
printer he's he began printing when he
was 14 years old down in Mesa Arizona
and he's been printing his whole life so
he knows printing right now and when he
moved to Provo he brought all of his old
printing material all of his old
printing printing presses that pending
the type and everything and started
showing to people and it just sort of
expanded from that from the original
presses up to what we have here today
first thing they experience is learning
about the printing using movable metal
type is beginning with the Johannes
Gutenberg printing press in 1450 this is
a replica of the jhanas Gutenberg
printing press the first read printed
using movable metal type this press
basically what this is it's a converted
all that press didn't burn 20 he had to
figure out a way to press paper against
the inky type he saw the old wallet
president wine presses they hadn't said
I'll use that
that's what is you have a screw down the
middle there and handle through turn
that handle or is that flat board called
a platen
it's just a I'm all in France a wine
press and then he built this place this
is a place to put the type this is
called the bed of the press
and this is where you put the type after
you have the type made you put the type
in here now every letter in here is an
individual piece of type but in one
letter at a time next thing we need in
order to print is ink now you think
there'd be no problem with the ink
because scribes have been using ink for
generations but there's a problem with
their ink very thin water-based ink was
just fine for the scribes riding with
quill pens but it didn't work here to
depend on it runs all over he needs a
thick sticky black ink just stick to the
surface of the type he took linseed oil
boiled it down the Pulte like this until
it became thick and sticky but linseed
oil
even if his thick and sticky is still
clear in order to make it black he took
matte black or soot and let oxide and
copper oxide made a beautiful thick
sticky black ink they tell me the extra
saith quality has never been exceeded in
the world I don't know about that but he
used that's what he used this is modern
printers ink they still use boil then so
linseed oil for the base of their
printers ink but they use different
pigments they don't use a lead oxide and
copper oxide for health reasons they use
different pigments so now I take and
smear some ink out here on the egg stone
and I take home and get them covered
with the ink
now I have to work these for just a
couple of minutes because I want to get
that ink nice and smooth and even over
the full face of the ball I don't want
any lumps or any bare spots now in order
to make these ink bowls
he took a wooden bowl put a wooden
handle on it he stuffed it with
horsehair and he covered with goose skin
why use goose skin we don't know but
it's interesting that he did because you
see Johanna's Gutenberg his birth name
was not Gutenberg his birth name was
Johannes get a splice get a splice is
German for goose mate I should like to
go through life with the name of goose
mate well he didn't like either so he
changed his name why do they pick the
name he did back in those days you had a
nice home there weren't a lot of nice
homes to line them up in a row number
him like we do so they wouldn't name
their homes while there gets a place
named his home good mountain home a
german youtuber go so joystick name is
home for his family names we known as
John is super good bird lollipops nice
and smooth and even this is the way you
ain't that you don't drag it across you
don't roll it cuz that fills it in make
black blobs you come straight down see
how I come straight down there's a real
art to doing this remember the crew that
does this particular job for some
strange reason is called a beater the
next thing we need
is something to print on Gutenberg did
not have to invent paper paper making
invented minute in China and the
knowledge of paper making had been
brought to Europe by explorers there's a
problem with their paper it's handmade
it has a hard slip finish was just fine
for the scribes with her oil-based ink
but did not take a good impression with
gooferz oil-based ink he has a soft in
the paper he did by slightly moistening
it you actually print on slightly
moisten paper this is the frisket it's
cut out there where I'm going to print
and this holds the paper in place as I
lay it down and lift it up so it doesn't
smear or tear so I fold this over under
and I pull the handle pull now notice
that plan it's just this wide our sheet
of papers that wide we only printed one
page you see the larger the platen the
more pressure it takes and we can't put
enough pressure on what this wouldn't
press so we crank it out and pull a
handle again
and they're two pages of the Gutenberg
Bible printed on a good bird press using
Gutenberg type we have here in a pond
electric Pothier printers metal he did
to 600 degrees and that 600 degrees it
runs just like water see that it runs
just like water at 600 degrees now I
know take a little full of it pulled it
in my board in my type castor here this
is the type castor I take a ladle full
of metal or give my type caster I
spilled some in there turn it over open
it up and there's the metal that I just
poured in there now this cold steel has
absorbed a lot of that heat so it's
already cooled it off enough but I can
handle it
there it is my mold still on top I break
the mold off and there I have on the end
of it
I let her be I just cast a letter B
after you have all of this type cast it
takes hundreds and thousands a piece of
the type doesn't want to just dump them
in a big pile so he built boxes for him
though the box for ABCD maybe put his
capital letters up here capital ABCD efg
and his small letters down here ABCD ft
he put his capital letters in the upper
part of the case
but the small letters in the lower part
of the case so even today we call
capital letters uppercase letters small
letters lowercase letters as for good
bird put his type and we're printers
still keep their type today uppercase
and lowercase this is the press that
printed the Deseret News the Deseret
News the first newspaper in the
Intermountain West the first edition was
June 15th 1850 now 1850 that's just four
hundred years after Gutenberg invented
this printing process and this is state
of the art and what I want you to notice
after four hundred years
everything is still the same as what
Gutenberg invented well the press is a
Ramage press is iron deadwood other than
that everything is still the same the
type is still hand cast and podcaster
still said it plays one letter at time
we still put the paper up here on the
tip and frisket one advancement after
400 years now instead of using the ink
balls to ink the type now we use ink
rollers for hundred years this is the
line of type the line of type with a
first major advancement in printing
after Gutenberg the Linotype was
invented mister Mergenthaler in 1886 now
the way this works appear in this
magazine is the matrix of all the modern
alphabet this is a line of type matrix
matrix is a mold that is the line of
type matrix and they're up here in this
magazine when you do you press it up a
key
and that these type comes down out of
here comes down here lines up here in a
roll here you do it just by typing it in
and once you have them all lined up you
can put this is called a space band that
goes in between words and that
automatically justifies your left and
right and once you have all done you
pull the handle here it moves over here
in front of that pot a printers metal
and pump moves up presses into the
matrix and how it drops a full line of
type that is the line of type 1886 this
machine was used by all the printers all
newspapers elet print shops in the world
till the 1970s and then the computer
took over it without a museum like this
this whole process would be totally lost
in fact it is being lost right now this
printing process we use writing with
movable metal type it's being lost today
going into the digital age and this is
so important because this is basically
this is where the modern technology came
from the printer on your computer began
it started developed from a press like
this this is why it's important to know
about printing about writing about
keeping records
now on book TV a literary tour of Provo
Utah with the help of our local cable
partner Comcast next we speak with Susan
Rue whose book are we there yet
talks about the rise of family vacations
after World War two
the family vacation is an American
invention the way we do it here in
America is to take a road trip and while
many families especially well-to-do
families got in their cars in the 1920s
and 1930s and many people took railroad
vacations in the nineteenth century it's
really not until after World War two
that the American Road Trip or the
American family vacation as we know it
is invented the family vacation was
brought about by an unusual confluence
of circumstances a lot of things
happened as a result of having fought
World War two after World War Two the
vets came home and they wanted to take
their families to see America so many of
them made the pilgrimage to Washington
DC or to the White House or to parks
that was one impetus for the park seeing
democracy on the road and another
impetus for the family road trip was the
vets again coming home and there was a
very young marriage age and it started
what we know today as the baby boom and
so the baby boom families were larger
families were being formed at a rapid
rate and the cheapest way to go on a
vacation is to put everybody in the car
so that sets out from a social aspect
the idea of the family vacation the
government had a part in the family
vacation by making roads for families to
travel on and in 1956 the interstate
Federal Highway Act was signed which
provided for highways to be built all
across America and it was really a civil
defense measure but it did benefit
people in the fact that there were all
these funds available to the states to
build roads and not just any road this
is the kind of road where you don't have
to stop so these were roads that could
go across States without Turnpike fees
and so people could travel pretty far in
a day because of these interstate
highways I think vets wanted to come
home and see the America
they had fought for in the war that
their buddies had lost their lives for
this big massive effort of World War two
ended and people came home and they
wanted to see what what was America if
you lived in the East you might want to
go west
you wanted to see what kind of a place
this was that you had fought for and
initially after the war was difficult to
get cars cars production of cars had
been slowed down during the war because
all the materials went to defense but
after the war by 1946 they are producing
new models of cars and Detroit began
producing new models of cars every year
and so the production of cars is a vital
part of the American family vacation and
in creating this consumer economy where
you had to have a car it's before the
days of two cars in the garage you had
to have a car so car ownership just rose
dramatically allowing people to go on
vacation in their cars today you and
your family can enjoy the vacation
thrills of this spot and no matter where
you live you can reach it quickly
comfortably and without most economies
travel this year the roads to romance
the places you have always wanted to go
and when you travel go in one of the
quality motorcars your neighborhood
Chevrolet dealer has to offer it will be
your magic carpet that will carry you to
the land of your heart's desire national
parks as they opened in 1946 were
completely overwhelmed with all of the
visitors people in Yellowstone would
drive through the parks and not find a
place to stay so the national parks
became extremely crowded and they came
up with a program and in 1956 they
expanded all the parks mission 66-56 and
they began to you know mission six start
in 56 it was mission 66 to be completed
in 66 so they tried to accommodate more
people but I argue that by taking their
children to the parks many children who
grow up in cities parents are trying to
instill in them some kind of an
appreciation for nature because the
national parks were wild and they were
wild and they were dangerous places for
children many children were hurt at
national parks children were bitten by
bears and you know fell into rivers and
and some children even died so the
national parks were a way to take the
children back to just raw nature and and
I think a lot of those children were the
ones who in the 1970s began these
environmental movements and took back
the parks you know if you think of
Yosemite in the protests in Yosemite
these are a way for people to learn
about the country but also to learn
about their idea of nature now I think
it also for many children and families
it created by going to Washington DC in
these American places it created a sense
of citizenship that I am a citizen of
this great country and at the same time
people who did not have the full rights
of citizenship this created in them a
frustration and a desire to change and I
argue that the strength of the civil
rights movement the roots of it come
for many of these families who
african-american families many of whom
had migrated to the north to Detroit to
Chicago that got back on the road wanted
to see their relatives and they were
turned away from restaurants they were
directed to substandard restrooms in gas
stations they couldn't eat at
restaurants even a place like Howard
Johnsons
wouldn't serve them even in Maryland
just really close by the Capitol and so
for these people it wasn't so much a
victory lap as it was a way for them to
see that things needed to change that
they had given their time to serve in
this country but they couldn't be served
in a cafeteria something was wrong here
there were entrepreneurs in the black
community in the african-american
communities all over the country but
especially in the south where
segregation was legal who would create
businesses and they would create
roadside homes places to stay motels as
motels were invented and a very
enterprising man named Victor Greene in
New York City he was a mail carrier and
he contacted other mail carriers and
compiled a listing of places where
African American families could stay and
where they would know that they would be
welcomed and this led to various other
guides this guide was called the green
book was published from 1936 until the
mid-1960s and these guides would help
direct African American businessmen and
African American families to places
where they would not be humiliated in
front of their children because it was a
humiliating experience for them so I
found this story in the civil rights
hearings and I also found a version of
this story in the trade journal for
owners of motels and basically the trade
journal was saying the civil rights
movement is something you need to to
take notice of and you need to deal with
it with your customers
because for years for instance if a rich
family white family had been on the road
with servants they would have to stay in
other accommodations they would not put
them up and this is true you know until
the early 1960s in Las Vegas so this is
a man named Ralph Sims and Ralph Sims
owned an appliance store and his
appliance positions worth you know half
a million dollars and he and his family
traveled to st. Petersburg Florida this
is in the early 60s and when Sims asked
the price of a room the motel owner
quoted the outrageous price of $50,000
Sims Ralph Sims said he would pay double
the rate that the proprietor charged
others because and he said I've got two
kids out there they haven't had a good
meal all day were all exhausted and we
can't find any place to sleep the motel
manager refused that night the Sims
family who were negroes the word at the
times tried to doze curled up inside
their parked car counting the minutes
until sunrise when they would begin
hunting a colored restaurant for
business so you can see in this story
that they wanted they were wealthy
enough they wanted to eat where they
wanted to eat they didn't want to just
eat at a restaurant for colored people
and so they they had enough money to go
anywhere but they weren't being allowed
to exercise their rights of citizenship
and this story of Ralph Sims and his
family was read into the Congressional
Record by Senator Javits in the civil
rights bill and Roy Wilkins you know
Secretary of the n-double a-c-p got up
and said imagine yourself he said to the
Senators imagine yourself right now in
July in this country getting the station
wagon packed and going on a vacation
with your family
imagine being turned away imagine not
being able to get a place to eat or a
place to stay and he used that image of
the family of Ralph Sims to convince
this
committee that something had to change
that public accommodations had to be
open to all all citizens in America as I
was thinking about family vacations and
getting started on this book I wanted to
tell the story of the real family
vacation the history of the family
vacation not the family vacation as
television shows showed it on Ozzie and
Harriet or Leave It to Beaver because
those aren't real depictions of reality
and I had spent 15 years living on the
south side of Chicago I raised my
children in an integrated racially
integrated community on the south side
and I knew of the civil rights struggles
and so I was aware of this but most of
it was I read the histories almost all
the histories talked about the buses the
trains and something had not been done
on the individual family experiences and
I wanted to tell the families story what
was it like for a family getting in a
car what would their experience be well
I think the family vacation had its
heyday in the 50s and 60s Disneyland
opens 1955 people rush to go to
Disneyland by the time those children
grow up and become teenagers in the late
60s and early 70s the enthusiasm for
family vacations wanes and part of it is
that the children are growing up the
baby boomers the people of my generation
are growing up but part of it is society
is changing and it's not cool to get in
the car with your family there was a lot
more sexual freedom there was a lot of
protest the Vietnam War we wouldn't want
to overestimate that but there was
certainly the arising of a
counterculture and the idea that a
vacation really was for couples instead
of for families and you couple that with
the deregulation of air fares makes it
cheaper to fly and then the gas crisis
in 90
73 the Arab oil embargo people are
waiting in long lines for gasoline
gasoline becomes expensive and when
gasoline becomes expensive the vacation
becomes expensive I think it's important
to know about the family vacation
because it tells us a lot about how
families have changed in history when we
talk about the family vacation that's
you know lampooned in these movies you
know we always have this view of this
nuclear family in fact the most in fact
most of the pictures show a mom a dad
and a boy and a girl and maybe a dog so
this is very idealized view or the
family vacation
well families are not like that anymore
a family vacation now might be three
generations it might be having grandma
along and as the grandma now I really
hope that that's true
it might be a married couple of a
same-sex couple now they have places
they can go and not be turned away it
might be in an array shal couple it
might be a single mom with a bunch of
kids so I think as our ideas of family
have become more flexible I hope and it
seems to me that places are opening up
if you go on a vacation with your one
child to me that's a family vacation
you're creating a family time you don't
have to look like Auggie and Harriet to
have a good family vacation for more
information on book TV's recent visit to
Provo and the many other destinations on
our cities tour go to c-span org slash
cities tour
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals happening around the
country on Saturday July 16th it's the
annual Harlem Book Fair then in August
the 2nd annual Mississippi Book Festival
will be held at the State Capitol in
Jackson coming up in September it's the
Brooklyn Book Festival held in downtown
Brooklyn and on Saturday September 24th
for the 16th year in a row book TV we'll
have live coverage of the National Book
Festival hosted by the Library of
Congress at the Washington Convention
Center for more information about the
book fairs and festivals book TV will be
covering and to watch previous festival
coverage click the book fairs tab on our
website book TV org
and you're watching book TV on c-span -
joining us now from Chicago and the
publishers convention is Ron Charles who
is the editor of Washington Post's book
world
mr. Charles what do you do for a living
I assign most of the daily reviews in
the Washington Post and every Wednesday
I write my own review a book of books
yes so how many books a week seven books
we we review 20 books a week
yeah not bad and we get about 150 though
so most go into the flames I'm afraid
but about 20 books a week or reviewed in
the pose why isn't there a book section
standalone book section there is a
standalone book section online but we
decided about four years ago to spread
the reviews out through the paper to try
and see if we could find more readers it
seems like a disaster at the time to me
but I have had to admit that we do in
fact have more readers for book reviews
now we just put them in places that
people read more book world the old book
well the supplement was much beloved but
tended to be the section that everyone
put aside to read later when they had
time and that that time never came
whereas now we're in there every day in
style we're in the weekend art section
we're in Outlook every Sunday people see
our reviews more on the paper what kind
of books do you review I tend review
only literary fiction but we review a
lot of political books a lot of history
science biography we do a lot of arts
coverage on the week on Sundays books
about the history of film and theater
and that sort of thing why do you stick
to fiction mostly because I don't have
to know anything
that's the end of your answer that's
pretty much if you interview a
nonfiction book I mean you have to be an
expert in five days on this subject you
know who you had to go up against David
McCullough and critique his history of
such-and-such
whereas if it's fiction you know I can
just sit back and say whatever I want do
the publishers want to have their books
reviewed in Washington country they say
they do I think they do there are fewer
outlets than there used to be for book
reviews unfortunately around the country
our reviews get syndicated across the
country so yeah I think it's an
important of the important venues for
book criticism Jonathan Yardley used to
be Jonathan we lost Jonathan he retired
yeah what my colleague for many many
years every week sometimes twice a week
for many years before I got to the post
yeah and so but now we still have David
we still have Michael Derna though so
every Thursday another one of our
Pulitzer prize-winning book critics so
Ron Charles how did you get into this
business I was an English teacher for
many years and which I loved it's still
my favorite job but the paper grading
was just wearing me down I just thought
if I graded one more paper I would kill
someone and a student a student's mother
suggested I review books instead and so
I just went to a book store bought a
book off the new fiction table wrote up
a review and sent it to the Christian
Science Monitor and they bought it and
asked for more so how long were you at
the monitor seven years I was their book
critic and their book editor there
can a good review or a bad review sell
or hurt book sells jeez that is the
question we all want the answer to there
is some academic research that I've read
that suggests that a review in a major
newspaper has a marginal positive effect
on sales but it doesn't apparently
matter whether the review is positive or
negative it's just getting the cover and
the name out there helps a little bit
but I know there are cases where very
very positive reviews have pushed books
onto the bestseller list and once you
get there of course the best-selling
let's just sort of sticky and you tend
to stay there will the post continue to
print book reviews Oh point yes and not
only I mean I know we will because we
just for the first time in many years
added staff to the book section which is
very exciting for us so yeah we're
committed to it so what are some of the
books that are coming out that you're
looking forward which some of the big
one this fall is gonna be Cole's of the
whiteheads book about the Underground
Railroad which imagines I've read it but
it imagines that the Underground
Railroad during before the Civil War was
an actual railroad underground and
everybody said it's just fantastic
Annie Pru has a huge novel coming out in
a few weeks people are very excited
about Robert Nolan Butler the Pulitzer
Prize winner he has a book coming out
that apparently reaches back to his
Vietnam War days it's supposed to be
wonderful - who are some of your go-to
authors I am a sucker for anything and
Tyler writes and patch it's always
fantastic I love Jonathan Franzen
had no Brian's novels were always
wonderful still I think he's in her 80s
the last book a few weeks ago was just
fantastic I couldn't believe it I am
amazed by the number of really finalists
we have in this country and the number
that we keep producing every year that I
mean I hate to say it but our writing
programs are really good at producing
fine fiction writers
there are many more books being produced
that we want to review than we have room
for many more I won't say that every
review we run is a recommendation but
more and more I think we are turning
that way because people need direction
they go into the bookstore and it's just
overwhelming there are so many books and
so they want to know basically you know
what should I read and it's getting
harder and harder I think to justify
using our limited space to tell people
here's a book you've never heard of
don't read it there's no danger of them
finding that book anyhow so I tend to I
don't want a lot of pans in the paper
unless there are very big name books and
I feel like I can save people time
otherwise I want to point people to
books that they'll enjoy they want to
read being Washington is it important
that you review a lot of the political
books that come on it is people do turn
to us for that I think we have a lot of
expertise in that area my colleague
Steve Livingston the non fiction editor
assigns a lot of political books quickly
now with the election coming up but all
the time we're right on the history
books right on the policy books right on
any penny books that would impinge on
law or government yeah I think we
specialize in those books how do you
develop your bestseller list the
bestseller list is generated for us by
Nielsen's and they take from the trust
you know Maryland Virginia and DC yes
and that information is just given to us
and then we filter out some things like
textbooks or other things that might
show up you know we you know certain
times of the year as everyone else does
with their bestseller list to make it go
here to the editorial judgment what are
some of the best selling books in
Washington right
gosh I wish I'd looked at the list it
doesn't tend to different that much from
the national list once in a while a
conference will come in or they'll be
some other event and that'll push books
up on the list or someone will visit
that'll do it someone will come to our
great bookstore politics and prose no
they'll move 300 copies that week and
that'll push us up on the list but in
general the list tracks pretty much the
national list but we've keep looking at
that seeing if we should switch and we
kind of like the idiosyncratic elements
that pop up once in a while but it isn't
that different Ron Charles here here at
the publishers convention in Chicago
what's the importance of this to you I
get to meet a lot of publicists that I
talk to all year by email
they give me good recommendations some
of them have become good friends trusted
friends even they tell me what to look
for that's probably the biggest benefit
how's you to meet some authors sometime
which is fun I can set up future
interviews with them sometimes I'm just
you know a fan and I can just
get an autograph or you know kind of
embarrass myself that kind of thing do
you do anything electronical with the
book reviews we tweet them we Facebook
them I've started to experiment with
vine videos I've got this comic series
the satirical series about books that I
do once in a while that post wants me to
start up again oh hello I'm Ron Charles
you may know me as the book critic for a
major American newspaper no not that one
in response to our previous episode we
received literally dozen of kind
messages from all over my grandparents
retirement home clearly we're meeting a
need in these hectic hurly-burly times
you need book criticism it's fast fun
and incredibly hip people often ask me
how long can you keep this up despite
the workload the expense the humiliation
it's a good question I mean here we are
at the dog why don't know how many
episodes they've been so far but still
the show seems just as Trenchard and
challenging as it did way back at the
beginning this week's new book is a
blockbuster by Jonathan Franzen called
freedom you may already have heard a lot
about this novel because the literary
chat started long before anyone could
actually buy it the New York Times ran
their first review of Jonathan Franzen's
freedom back in 1834 they say it's a
liming lapidary masterpiece what does it
mean pop I don't know I don't reckon
anybody knows Franzen has even been on
the cover of Time magazine
do you realize what a big deal that is
we're talking the cover of Time magazine
here and three weeks before the book
even came out president obama was
fighting